nothing in game satisfies like Landing
that one perfectly placed long-range
shot
[Applause]
virtual sniping comes in such a spectrum
of flavors from Call of Duty quick
Scopes and CS go up picks to measuring
your range and bullet dropping games
like armor and Sniper Elite but games
don't always get the humble sniper rifle
quite right we've come here to the Royal
armories Museum in the UK to break down
the differences between the virtual
sniper rifle and its real counterparts
and unpack some of those dubious tropes
I think it's a strong misconception that
the Barrack 50 caliber that that was a
sniper rifle they're not designed for
precision they are not precise at say a
thousand yards
but with a range of options available to
Virtual snipers where the games fall
short and how are they on target
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
before we can understand where exactly
games are getting sniping wrong we must
first understand what exactly a sniper
is and how they've developed through
history
in the Middle Ages the term Marksman was
given to Royal archers of the palace
guard but it wasn't until the 16th
century where competitions celebrating
Feats of firearm accuracy started to
appear largely taking place across what
we now know as Germany these shoots and
fests allowed for masters of archibus
and musket to win such grand prizes like
pairs of oxen or pouches of gold one of
the earliest examples of what we'd
consider a sniper shot in Warfare took
place during the Battle of Litchfield in
1642 during the English Civil War where
accounts state that a deaf poacher by
the name of John diet made a musket shot
from some 180 yards from a cathedral
Spire killing Parliament forces General
Lord Brooke however the title of sniper
originated in the 1770s among soldiers
in British India in reference to Skilled
Shooters who are able to hunt
challenging game birds called Snipes but
what we think of as the iconic sniper
and their rifle didn't become
established until much later so most of
the history of the sniper rifle is the
history of the rifle or even just of the
long gun generally and it's not until we
reach the American Civil War maybe where
we start to see things like the Davidson
scope fitted to say Whitworth rifles in
relatively rare cases the vast majority
of sharp shooting in the American Civil
War pretty much what we think of as
sniping today was done without just with
iron sights even in the first world war
most of the sniping is done with some
form of Ironside but that's where we
start to see specialized sniper rifles
but the rifles themselves aren't haven't
really changed they're just ideally
selected for accuracy and then of course
Drilling and tapping the receiver for a
scope and then when you get a scope on
it that's where we really get our iconic
sniper rifle what we consider a sniper
rifle really originated out of World War
One Germany went to war in 1914 with
light infantry units like the Jaeger
battalions which had a long tradition of
Woodland combat camouflage and patience
this was supplemented as well by the
country's long tradition of game hunting
and Germany having a leading industry of
high quality lenses and Optics by the
end of 1914 Germany had issued 15 000
Mauser model g98 scope rifles reserved
for the best Marksman of a battalion
however other powers like Great Britain
entered the war without specific
military Doctrine around individual
marksmen Sharpshooters or telescopic
sites seeing the effects that German
snipers had both pragmatically and
psychologically Britain founded their
own sniper schools on the Western Front
between the two World Wars many nations
would drop their specialized sniper
units but Marksman would reappear as an
important Battlefield role as early as
the first campaigns in World War II
sniper trading varied between countries
with some forces putting more emphasis
on the role than others the arms they
were issued were also just as varied but
many of them gained a reputation
throughout the war and became iconic
themselves many of them recognizable in
games and movies today be that the
Soviet moves in Nagant the German KR 98k
the britishly Enfield or the American
Springfield and m1c Garand sniper rifles
continue to be in implemented through
almost every major conflict into the
modern day from Korea Vietnam the Middle
East and further these rifles continue
to be adapted and approved upon with
modern rifles having the potential to
shoot accurately at distances up in
excess of 1000 meters
sniper rifles have been an option in a
game's Arsenal almost since you were
able to pull a virtual trigger
regardless of the genre they find
themselves in from early 90s Shooters
like Medal of Honor or GoldenEye 007
with rudimentary scope views to strategy
games like Fallout and Commando which
gave tacticians the option to take out
enemies from range
or even within the arcade where fans of
light gun games had the option of
sitting behind a physical plastic rifle
in sniper scope battling with a risk
reward of high damage and punishing
misses many players have always felt an
alert to place those single powerful
shots whether you're the top Fragger in
Counter-Strike or in a single player
experience taking the role of a chrome
dome assassin in the Hitman franchise
the main draw of virtual sniping has
been the range at which you are able to
engage and the satisfaction that comes
with hitting that long-range shot but
there's often been a hard limit not just
because of the range of the weapon but
because of the render distance each
game's engine is able to draw games like
Battlefield 1942 had extremely
impressive scales and environment for
their time but the render distance of
the games of that era limited how much
you could take advantage of the sniper
rifles range as games developed render
distances became less of an issue Maps
became bigger and Graphics engines
became more and more powerful so instead
developers looked to balance the
ballistics of the weapon within their
virtual Universe rather than focus on
what the realistic potential might be
this is what led to tropes like
exaggerated bullet drop a gameplay
equalizer that effectively squashed the
effective range of what is supposed to
be a long-ranged weapon in the case of
Battlefield 3 developers literally
increased the in-game gravity for the
bullets of most non-recon weapons to
allow the sniper's range to make more
sense within their world and let those
rifles feel like they had a much longer
range than the rest of this election
while games have experimented with how
to balance the player's ability to shoot
accurately implementing things like
scope sway bullet drop or steadying the
weapon with holding their virtual breath
they've also had to consider how other
players are able to spot a sniper this
has led to gameplay elements like Tracer
rounds Vapor Trails and to an extent
kill cams but these all take place after
the shot is fired and when you're
potentially already respawning but the
most common gameplay fix that sculpting
Shooters find themselves having to deal
with is that Infamous Trope of scope
lint originally this was a mechanic to
help players find snipers in single
player missions and games to ease
frustration and to allow for the pace of
the campaign to remain high however with
the release of Battlefield 3 and its
larger Maps scope lint became much more
commonplace in multiplayer 2.
and as games have developed Graphics
have become so sophisticated that
without assistance player models would
have no trouble blending into the
background bringing us to now where
unless you're playing a title that leans
into the realism like escape from tarkov
or armor you can be pretty sure that
that scope of yours is going to light up
the sky
while in reality it wouldn't be nearly
as commonplace as it is in games it has
been a consideration through the history
of scope design and there have long been
strategies to avoid this issue first
with the use of foliage camouflage
shooter placement and concealment while
more modern Scopes are often fit with a
kill flash a mesh of material designed
to prevent light bouncing off the large
piece of glass atop a user's weapon
while glint isn't realistic least of all
when there isn't a light source position
to cause one they are for better or
worse and important gameplay element a
player finding that perfect advantage
and being able to make pot shots at
range with impunity can be a lot of fun
for the one behind the trigger but for
the sake of balance especially within
multiplayer matches the wider player
base as a whole must be considered with
these frustrations having to be
addressed to give those on the receiving
end of a shot of Fighting Chance
[Applause]
and yet personally it's not when snipers
are far away that make for the most
frustrating moments it's when they're
right in your face
quick scoping is yet another way sniper
rifles have had to fit into the
environment and to the player base's
tastes more so than most any other
weapon we do a deeper dive into the
phenomenon of quick scoping in our
intervention episode Link in the top
right for that but it has undoubtedly
been a consideration as games have grown
beyond the days of Call of Duty 4. but
for the longest time most Call of Duty
maps were relatively small at least by
today's comparisons but despite the
sniper rifle being just about the worst
weapon you could think to run and Gun
with the small matter of realism wasn't
about to deter a gamer's desire for
those powerful rifles and satisfying
One-Shot kills
another consideration games have to make
is how to balance sniper rifles not just
the gameplay elements and how they work
within each different virtual world but
even down to the details of rifle to
rifle
I believe there's been a common
assumption among mainstream shooter fans
for maybe 20 years now the bolt action
sniper rifles do more damage than their
semi-automatic siblings I have memories
of that debate going back and forth when
I was playing games like Modern Warfare
2 and Battlefield and while FPS
enthusiasts or fans of more hardcore
titles might know it's not quite as
simple as that I think if you ask the
average gamer they'd Echo this very
thought it is a necessary concession
though as even if the rifles might fire
the same caliber and theoretically have
as much stopping power as each other
there has to be a trade-off between them
from a gameplay perspective and
adjustments made so that the rifles are
balanced within the microcosm of the
game and the weapon class for most
titles if the semi-automatic rifles do
the same damage as the bolt action ones
there would be much less reason to pick
one over the other not only affecting
balance but also having a knock-on
effect to how much variety and player
choice is available regardless of how
much each game wants to adjust their
Weaponry it is nonetheless a factor that
developers have to consider when
building their selection of snipers
whether their DMR cars bolt actions or
huge anti-material rifles the latter of
which being much more than a simple
sniper rifle I think there's a strong
misconception that the classic
the Barrett 50 caliber that that was a
sniper rifle or is a sniper rifle and in
this case that rifle was explicitly
developed as what's called an
anti-materiel rifle El at the end and
that's a French derived word referring
to military kit and Equipment the big
stuff they're not designed for precision
they are not precise at say a thousand
yards they can be made so and have been
in the British forces what they were
actually acquired for because they have
used the the Barrett was explosive
Ordnance disposal they discovered that
amount of energy and relatively flat
trajectory could also equate to sniping
anybody while it's very rare that we see
a weapon like this implemented in a
fashion close to its reality with only a
few games like armor touching upon the
anti-material nature it's not surprising
that more mainstream Shooters group
together these different classes of
long-range Weaponry especially when the
boom of a virtual Barrack can be so
appealing to their audiences
however for those who favor a little
more realism and authenticity in their
sniping there is an ever-expanding
library of games and mechanics that
cater to that craving as well slower
paced titles like Sniper Ghost Warrior
escape from tarkov armor and Sniper
Elite give players the opportunity to
lean more into the experience of sniping
making you work a little bit harder to
get that satisfying One-Shot kill or
even allowing you to bring in a friend
as your spotter a role that is crucial
to sniping in reality but so rarely
implemented in games
these titles lean much more into the
realism angle not only simulating a
physical round leaving your virtual
Barrel but by needing players to lead
their targets and just for bullet drop
on top of that considerations like
ballistics windage and bullet
penetration were becoming more
commonplace especially in titles on the
simulation end of the virtual sniping
Spectrum this Echoes the reality of real
world snipers having to factor in
elements like range wind direction and
velocity as well as altitude elevation
ambient temperature and extreme
distances of around a thousand yards and
Beyond even the Coriolis effect of the
Earth spinning
foreign
faults virtual sniper rifles exist
across a huge Spectrum in games and in
that I see an enormous strength I love
sniping it's one of my favorite play
Styles and the long range firefights and
Feats of accuracy that only sniper
rifles can offer can create some of the
most intense and satisfying moments in
gaming
I can still remember my favorite rifle
in Battlefield 3 the sv98 the first time
I saw the Barrett at the end of cod 4's
all gillied up punching through armor so
I can steal a pmc's loot from long range
in tarkov and I still have memories of
me playing the first Sniper Elite on my
original Xbox back in 2005.
I've talked about how sniping falls on a
wide spectrum in games from the action
packed to the more slower paced and
considered but like we talked about in
the shotguns episode it's the variety of
those experiences that I both enjoy and
admire their effectiveness is without
doubt so many games of Counter-Strike
and valorant have players saving their
money for a sniper rifle or scrambling
to pick up a dropped orb or operator in
other Battle Royale like pubg or
fortnite a sniper rifle will so often
get priority spot in the weapon slots
and the idea of a long-ranged high
damage scope weapon is so Broad and
understood that they can fit into any
setting from the wild west to the far
future
foreign
despite the differences of how sniper
rifles and sniping are handled across
games and genres and how far they're
often removed from reality it remains as
no surprise that they've become such a
popular option in Virtual arsenals
I think the the big appeal of a
quote-unquote sniper rifle of whatever
type whether you're watching sniper
duels and Saving Private Ryan or Enemy
At The Gates or something or whether
you're shooting at the longest possible
distance you can in Battlefield 4 or
something I think it's that change of
pace as soon as you move to the sniper
role everything slows down and you're
just you're focusing right in on that
one one enemy one shot one kill and I
think that will always appeal even if
you're doing it with a rail gun or
something or with a you know
hopefully we'll see some American Civil
War sharp shooting in games one day it
doesn't matter it's it's the same basic
idea slow methodical deadly
it's a new season of Loadout and we've
got many more episodes to come if you
enjoyed make sure you like the video
subscribe for more and let me know in
the comment section what you'd like to
see an episode on or reach out to me on
Twitter at a regular Dave if you want to
see more video game Firearms content you
can watch the previous series of the
show or check out our weekly series of
expert reacts where I show our friends
at the Royal armories a slew of guns to
break down until next time I've been
your host Dave Jewett thank you so much
for watching and I'll see you in the
next one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]